في كاليفورنيا بدات القصه بافتتاح اول
مطعم معام 1982 اليوم بعد نحو اربعين عاما
يملك سلسله مطاعم في جميع انحاء الولايات
المتحده واوروبا واسيا والشرق الاوسط
فك مشاهدينا السيد الطعام الفاخر هو
مايسترو مطبخ مهرجان العسكر لنحو ثلاثه
عقود مسؤول عن طهات عشاء ما بعد الحفله
ايضا ويملك نجمه باسمه في ممشى المشاهير
السيد باك وهو رائد لفكره المطابخ
المفتوحه في عالم المطاعم معروف ببيتزا
سالمون الشهيره التي يسافر لاجل هذا
الذواقه من جميع انحاء العالم ومن
كاليفورنيا مشاهدينا الى السعوديه الشيف
العالمي
اول مطاعنه في السعوديه
[موسيقى]
انا جعت انضم الينا من الرياضه الشيف
العالمي والفه اجانك طبعا اهلا بك وسعداء
بلقائك في هذا الصباح سال لعابي كما يقال
دعني اسالك اولا ما الذي اتى بك الى
الرياض لماذا الرياض وهل الدائقه السعوديه
مختلفه
من خلال تجربتك
السعوديه واحب الرياض لانني عندما كنت في
لوس انجلوس الكثير من السعوديين ياتون الي
ويقولون لي وفقا تعال الى الرياض لاننا
نحب طعمك وها انا الان في الرياض
هي سباكو هنا فياريال واخذ واجهات الرياض
الجديده وانا سعيد جدا لانني احصل على
المزيد عن الثقافه السعوديه وساتي بثقافه
ايضا
او حتى المشاهدين اللي عم بيتابعونا
استاذ
اسمك ارتبط بكثير حفلات الفاخره حفلات
العسكر حفلات اللي ما بعد الاوسكار
بهذا يعني نمط الحياه المرفه بشكل
رهيب هل الموضوع الان بعد كل هذه السنين
يتعلق
يعني المال والشهره ام باسعاد الناس
واعطائهم هذه التجربه الفريده
ان الوضع يتعلق بالحقيقه بجعل الناس
سعداء في هذا العمل في هذا المجال في هذه
الصناعه نريد ان يذهبون العملاء ان ياتون
ويذهبون الى بيوتهم بسعاده
بابتسامه المال ياتي ويذهب انا اكل واشرب
مثل الاثرياء اصلا ولكن ما يهمني الان هو
ان اقدم افضل طعام وان اجعل الناس
سعداء وهذا اهم شيء بالنسبه لي هل جربت
الاطباق السعوديه خلال زيارتك وما الذي
اليوم ستحضر لنا في صباح العربيه او تخصنا
في
اوكي اذا دعوني اظهر لكم بعض هذه الاطباق
المهمه هذه بيتزا السلمون المشهوره وهي
مفضله بالنسبه للجميع انا افتكرت هذه
البيتزا لجون كولينز وانا اكيد انكم
تعرفون جون كولينز هذه بيتزا السلمون وانا
اضعها الان الكافيار الفاخر دعوني اصنع
بيتزا من السلمان والكافيار ليد جونز لان
هذه مكوناتها المفضله وهذه من اشهر اطباقي
اطباقي الخاصه لم تكن على القائمه في
الامر الاولى واتى الي الكثير من
السعوديين للقولون اتي لنا بهذه البيتزا
بيتزا الشريره ولدينا هنا
او الكركند او ام الروبيان وهي بوحي اسيا
وانا من النمسا كما تعرفون وهذه كعكه
الجبنه الشهيره وهذه وهذا اول طبق مستوحى
من الثقافه السعوديه وانا اقول بس طيله
سعوديه وليس مغربيه مع الارز ومع
التمر
بالعجينه الرقائق المقرمشه من الخارج هي
مقرمشه من الخارج وطريه من الداخل وانا
ايضا هناك لدي هنا بعض افضل
الاطباق والمفضله وهي
شريحه توماهوك والمصنوعه من لحم وايجو
الاسترالي الشهير جدا وانا اعرف ان
السعوديين واهل المنطقه عنوان يحبون اللحم
وهذه هذا بعض السحر اليكم هذه السمكه
السمكه اتي اليكم بها وهذا السحر سيحصل
امامكم الان انها السمكه
هكذا تاتي السمكه في مطبخ الى الناس الى
العملاء القليل من
الفلفل الحار والكليل من الحلاوه وهاني
اترك هذه السمكه امامكم هنا هي افضل ما في
مطبخي
الجميل
ولديكم ايضا بعض الاطباق المصنوعه من
الباستا انا اصنع الكثير من الباستا في
مطبخي لدينا الباستا اضعها على النار
وبينما
اطبخ ترون هنا
صلصه مصنوعه من الفراوله وجرجناله وهي من
من الفطري البري وهذا موسم الفطر البري في
بعض مناطق اوروبا وانا هذه مكونات المهمه
جدا بالنسبه لي اذا هذه المكونات كلها
اطبخها امامكم في برنامجكم ويمكنكم ان
تشاهدوا انظروا الى هذه الباستا المستوحاه
من المطبخ النمساوي مطبخ بلدي العالم
يحبون الفاستا وهذه الفاستا مصنوعه باليد
صناعه يدويه هنا في المطبخ في مطعم وطبعت
بطبيعه الحال
البرمجان يرافق الباستا دائما
يا ريت يا ريتنا كنا معك في الرياض شاف
حتى نقدر نتذوق من هذه الاطعمه
وهذه
يعني الوصفات الشهيه جدا على ما يبدو حبيت
اني اسالك يعني مع كل هذا التنوع في مطبخك
هل بتقدر تقول بانه في هناك مكونات معينه
هي دائما تكون مصدر الهام
لك حتى للاطباق الجديده اللي بتبتكرها
في السعوديه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذا اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات